[Music]
hi no the question on everybody's mind
is now team Leanne or team Dorothy wow
that's intense
um I'm team Lauren okay my team Leanna
team Dorothy I think that
oh God
I'm team Dorothy okay that's I like that
answer and then also everyone on the
Reddit and servant saying that you're
this already of like solidified as like
a horror icon with this character of
Leanne so if I'm correct me from you
have more horror coming up and is that
something you want to lean more into
keep doing hard I do have another horror
coming up what can I say I'm a creepy
gal
um yeah I have the omen coming up and I
I don't know if I necessarily want to
keep leaning into horror for the next
couple of years I think I've kind of
rinsed that section and kind of happy to
do a little rom-com but for now I'm kind
of enjoying being in the in the horror
space but we'll see we'll see what's
stuck up well thank you for this amazing
performances Leanne and I can't wait to
see what you do next thank you